thanks to nordpass for sponsoring this
video here's a behind-the-scenes clip
from the production of nomadland what
you're seeing here is
almost the entire production crew for
the film and if you're familiar with
film production you know that this is an
incredibly small crew
even for a mid-size indie film like this
but director chloe zhao's approach to
shooting nomad land
was very different from how a lot of
directors approach shooting a film
nomad land is a film about fictional
protagonist fern as she
plots a course across the american
landscape
[Music]
it relies heavily on natural light
grounds its story in the incredible
landscapes and nature that serve as a
backdrop for life on the road
intimately explores the personal
experience of its characters
utilizes non-actors playing themselves
to populate the communities of nomadic
workers in the film
[Music]
adopts a probing reactive style of
handheld camera work
to evoke a sense of something that lies
beyond the frame
and utilizes non-continuity editing to
drift seamlessly from moment to moment
[Music]
michelle doesn't know
yeah you should take this one that that
one's kind of funky
let's look at this moment from nomad
land and pay close attention to the
visual characteristics of the scene
yeah these yours yeah there's a black
hole in every van
when i look at this some key visual
elements stand out to me the use of
natural light
the freedom of the handheld camera and
the use of a wide angle lens
i make them okay sure wow what is this
crochet
one or more of these elements are
present in almost every scene throughout
the film
the natural sunlight always low in the
sky and positioned to
backlight or sidelight the characters
the camera that is free to respond
and is clearly reacting to characters in
the moment
and the wide-angle lenses that keep the
environment and setting
always present in the frame even during
close-ups
it's easy to think zhao might just be
making these choices so the film looks a
certain way
but i think they are born out of an
approach to filmmaking
that pretty radically departs from how
your average production
operates
[Music]
to understand the context of zhao's work
and direction we need to travel back a
little ways in film history
40 years before zhao made nomad land
director terence malik released his
second film days of heaven
which focuses on a few characters within
a community of nomadic workers
it is firmly anchored in natural light
and nature
and intimately explores the personal
experience of its characters
before that malek's first film badlands
plotted a course
across the american landscape in the
thin red line and the new world
with the help of legendary
cinematographer emmanuel lebeske
malik would develop a probing reactive
style of handheld camera movement
that used very wide angle lenses to
ground the characters
in their environment and the nature that
surrounded them in malik's contemporary
films he would begin to work with a
combination of actors
and real people and would often abandon
continuity editing for something more
impressionistic
zhao is not merely a visual copy of
malik like malik
zhao and her cinematographer aren't
simply trying to create an interesting
visual style
they are making choices about how they
approach production
that are intimately connected to the
visual elements of the film we sometimes
tend to think of a film's style how it
looks and feels on screen as something
that is primarily an aesthetic decision
on the part of the director and crew
and it is in a way but thinking of how a
film looks as being primarily motivated
by trying to achieve a specific
look leads us to misunderstand why a
style develops organically
and why certain filmmakers are drawn to
that style
i think many stylistic movements in film
instead of being motivated by an attempt
to achieve a certain unique visual
aesthetic
instead arise out of a unique approach
to how the film is made
that results in a look on screen as a
byproduct
of the approach to production
so in theory we can look at these
stylistic characteristics of malek and
zhao's films
and potentially find the motivation
behind these choices
the natural light for example the use of
low natural sunlight looks good but it's
as much a choice of practicality and
function as it is style relying on
natural light means you don't need
as many crew members or as much bulky
lighting equipment
this allows you to be more reactive to
the environment to travel to locations
more quickly and affordably
and gives the actors more freedom to
move through their environments while
working
since they aren't confined to part of
the set that has been pre-lit
the wide-angle lenses not only do they
keep the surrounding location
visible but they make smooth adaptive
handheld camera movement
easier to pull off the camera's ability
to be reactive
allows more of the control of the scene
to be placed in the hands of the actors
allowing them to walk and stand where
they want and it puts less pressure on
non-actors to remember blocking and hit
marks
and shooting this way ends up shaping
how you edit and structure the film
no mad land like many of malik's films
trades out
continuity editing to operate mostly as
a kind of montage
scenes are rarely edited in continuity
in nomad land
instead most play out like this one
okay okay okay
the scene of linda mae leaving is
constructed out of just
four shots between each if you pay close
attention there's a
clear jump in time yet the cuts are
placed carefully enough that none of
them are visually jarring
this style of editing serves as a
stylistic device but it's also practical
it allows for longer more
improvisational takes to be shot and
then shaped into
a scene the editing and shooting styles
are interwoven
when you don't have to worry about
cutting to reverse shots you don't have
to worry about shooting them which means
you can be more flexible as you shoot
and it helps you
when working with golden hour natural
light shooting a whole scene like this
one in one take and then cutting it into
a final scene
allows you to work quickly in the brief
window of light you have available
and the roving camera is important for
editing scenes like this if the camera
was more static there would be fewer
opportunities to cut out sections
without creating a jump cut and again
this helps give the actors more
flexibility and freedom
i think most if not all of these
stylistic choices for both malik and
zhao
arise out of two motivating factors a
desire to ground their films in real
locations and people
and wanting to give themselves and the
people they put
in front of the camera freedom but why
is that freedom important to malik and
zhao
i think malik's style arose organically
as he
started radically changing how he
approached producing
films often shooting without scripts or
dialogue
and attempting to find the film as he
went in an interview with asc
zhao talks about taking a similar
approach
about making a film as a search for
answers to a question
rather than as a way to state something
you already know
xiao says it's almost a necessity for
him to explore something he wants to
understand about the world
about human existence about all these
bigger questions he had and that shines
through
his cinema that's why his films are so
intimate and so universal
at the same time he's exploring
questions that everyone can relate to
there's a lot of myself asking these
questions as well and by making these
films i was able to have
some of them explored for zhao making
the film is a process of discovering the
story the greater freedom and
flexibility and the approach to
production gives you a greater ability
to follow the story where it leads i
think this is why some other filmmakers
seem to come up empty
when they emulate or build upon malik's
style because
a visual style by itself isn't that
compelling you have to
understand the underlying reasons a
filmmaker came to that approach
or that style and chloe zhao seems to
understand this
in malik and in nomadland she finds a
style that is an extension and
progression of malik's influence
and not just an imitation malik's
influence has already been significant
but it's mostly manifested
in filmmakers emulating his visual
motifs for brief moments but not many
people are truly
adopting malik's philosophical and
practical approach and doing something
interesting with that and i'm not
insinuating that zhao's work is merely
derivative of malik instead
i think it may be part of the beginning
of a larger stylistic movement
one of my favorite writers derek sivers
once said that the first follower
is an underrated form of leadership that
the first
follower transforms a lone nut into a
leader
and even though zhao may be adopting an
approach that malek helped pioneer
it's an approach and style that lets the
voice of the filmmaker and
actors take center stage even though
aspects of the approach to production
may be similar zhao's work is distinct
from alex because her voice
is distinct and that's given a lot of
room to shine through with this approach
nomad land isn't a film malik would have
or could have made
his version would have looked very
different even if they shared overlap in
terms of visual style
and this is why i think chloe jean
deserves the best director oscar because
she's helping push the medium forward in
an interesting way
regardless of whether nomad land is the
best film out of the films
made by the best director nominees zhao
models the most inventive and
progressive use of direction
out of these nominees all these other
directors are operating at the top of
their class within
styles and approaches that are fairly
developed and entrenched
while i think zhao is helping to push
the medium
into new territory something i strongly
value as a film critic
viewer and filmmaker thank you so much
to nordpass for sponsoring this video
look
if you aren't using a password manager i
can almost guarantee you're
compromising in some way either you are
keeping track of your passwords in a
super inconvenient and annoying way
or you are compromising on the security
of your passwords and using
passwords that are too weak because they
are easy
to remember well you can solve both of
those problems
with a password manager and i recommend
nordpass the people who built nordpass
are the same people who built nordvpn
who i've been using for years they know
their security in fact when you encrypt
your passwords with nordpass they get
encrypted before they even
go to the server so there's no way that
nor pass could ever have access to your
passwords
you can access those passwords on all
your devices they'll autofill
on your phone on your computer it'll
generate
secure passwords for you it will check
to see if your passwords are secure
enough
and it even lets you share passwords
with
friends and family so your netflix
password isn't going to be
floating around in emails or text
messages insecurely anymore i'm a huge
fan
of this application i think you should
give it a try you can use it on one
device for free
or you can use my link go to
nordpass.com thomasflight
and there's a really great deal right
now you will get 70
off a two-year membership to nordpass
premium
and an entire extra month for free on
top of that so go to
nordpass.com thomasflight this is going
to
make your life easier and more secure at
the same time and it's really affordable
to do
so i highly recommend you check out
nordpass
[Music]
[Music]
you